legitimate businessman
what oh my god you know what that sounds
like he's a crook John owns a taxi cab
company he's organized on my side he's
the cab driver he knows everything about
boxing right I don't think so
I think he's gonna steal your son's
money and rob him blind credible
performance Melissa Leo earned an Oscar
for playing Alice Ward in the critically
acclaimed movie The Fighter she's played
more than a hundred characters over more
than three decades Leo started her
career on the soap opera all my children
that became a regular on the series
homicide life on the street she has
since appeared in a number of TV shows
and movies Melissa Leo now stars in the
new Showtime series I'm dying up here
based on the LA comedy scene in the
1970s Jim Carrey who got his start back
then is the executive producer Leo plays
Goldie the owner of a famed comedy club
that makes or breaks young stand-up
comics you won't go on in tonight's show
yes let me help you hmm
find a voice that women can relate I
have a voice why me it sheds light on
our mutual experiences huh then I'll put
you on the main stage front and center
my right hand to Carson it's Coffman
like Carly he's climbed like prior you
missing my point
yeah they're all up there on your stage
why is it any different for women
there's room for me too I just need your
stage to prove it when you're ready and
Melissa Leo is with us now good morning
good morning thanks for having me our
pleasure you look at something like this
and you hear comedy you think it's just
going to be funny there's drama to it
too what can viewers expect from this
well it is it's a drama about stand-up
comics is the way I like to see it and
we have both comics in the show playing
comics not necessarily the kind of
comedy they do in their own act nice
play which is always a little difficult
we have actors playing comics um a whole
bunch and and our both our writer and
our producer Michael Aguilera and David
Foote bought when they were younger had
dreams of stand-up comedy
everybody's touching something that they
I hadn't
had anything to do with any of it until
I joined them out in California sheath
pilot you play a very powerful figure
here you're Goldy and you run this club
that there and there and you basically
anoint these comedians who all want to
get on the Carson show on The Tonight
Show well you say anoint as if Goldie
thinks she's some kind of a God which
she does not
people think that of her but she does
not see that hers she knows funny from
not funny and that's all she's
interested in she doesn't care if you're
a boy or girl black or white Chinese she
doesn't care she cares if you're funny
and she doesn't want you in her club on
her stage if you're not gonna be funny
makes sense makes sense you are a method
actress take us through the process of
how you became cool Dee how long do we
have
method acting is a long disputed misused
term if you're acting I hope to god
you've got a method that's pretty much
super everything absolutely so why not
so for acting right so method acting
Goldie I had to use it sometimes as an
actor you use little or no technique you
can kind of step right into the role
look at your scene partner opposite you
and there you are doing the scene not so
for me and Goldie Goldie has talents
that I don't possess she has a way that
is not my way she presents herself to
the world in a way that is not the way I
present myself to the world
so she was what I call a long reach for
me to get a joy and a pleasure to play
because of that I'm more interested in
the character than myself that's part of
my method hey people day that know that
time remember Mitzi shore and her role
that she played in the comedy scene
there this isn't Mitzi sure you say
though not Mitzi hi Mitzi if you're what
I've never met her I hope to one day
no exactly right there's one woman who
did what Mitzi sure did in the time in
which she did it and that was to take a
club that had some funny guys in it but
it also had some improv some folk music
some poetry reading like a lot of clubs
across the country vaudeville had died
and where was that stand-up comic going
next and Mitzi shore in my opinion and
you can read it in the book I'm dying up
here invented a place for stand-up
comics painted the walls black put a
spotlight on the stage and said only
comics right and that was unprecedented
another that's the only way in which I'm
playing Mitzi shore at all I'm playing
Goldie her slag another stand-up comic
Jim Carrey is executive producer this
show as we mentioned how involved was he
on he was involved because we would not
have a show without Jim plain and simple
and he also gave us Michael Aguilar his
producer and in that way through Michael
involved himself as you see in the
photograph joined it at some dinners
gave us that kind of Jim Carrey
encouragement and stamp of approval to
it but Jim is taking care of himself and
and we're taking care of the show I like
to think of it like that
you work with a large ensemble of actors
comedians they are so funny on the show
I mean I find myself laughing at the
stand-up routines within the show but do
you mentor any of them off screen no I
don't I don't I mean I try to I'm always
talking about acting with whoever I'm
working with whether they want me to
it's also there's a lot of a lot of
learning that's going on you know the
actors are learning about stand-up and
indeed the stand-ups are learning about
acting and and we're all sharing
together it was one of the great joys
about the show and the excitement of
sharing it now is it's rare in the work
that I do that you have such a good time
such a sense of that camaraderie that we
often imagine is there yeah and in the
shooting of I'm dying up there we really
love each other you can see that comes
because it comes in yes Melissa we thank
you for being here at Memorial Day
Melissa Leo I'm dying up here premieres
Sunday night on Showtime a division of
CBS I love to all the vets and there
the first episode is streaming online
for free right now